you may recognize DreamWorks as the
little boy fishing while sat on a
crescent moon but you probably didn't
realize that all these years he's
actually been fishing for a new owner
I'm Simon and this is your entertainment
news update DreamWorks Animation the
studio behind the Shrek in Kung Fu Panda
films has been trying to sell itself for
years and now it appears cable company
Comcast is preparing to make a deal The
Wall Street Journal reports that Comcast
is in talks to buy the company for more
than three billion dollars as The Wall
Street Journal explains buying
DreamWorks Animation would allow Comcast
to better compete with Disney in the
family entertainment space whose family
properties produced by illumination
entertainment include Despicable Me and
minions among others it is possible that
talks between Comcast's and DreamWorks
Animation do not amount to anything if
the three billion dollar figure is
accurate its substantially above
DreamWorks Animation's current 2.3
billion market cap under the leadership
of CEO Jeffrey Katzenberg DreamWorks
Animation has been looking for a buyer
for the past few years meeting with
companies like Softbank and Hasbro
if the Comcast deal goes through and
Katzenberg departs the company he would
receive twenty one point nine million
dollars DreamWorks Animation is one of
the last major studios not owned by a
bigger company in 2004 the company spun
off from DreamWorks SKG a wider
entertainment firm founded in 1994 by
Katzenberg Steven Spielberg and David
Geffen do you think it's all oger for
Shrek and Friends let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at the jagan or thanks for
watching and for all your entertainment
news keep it gamespot